- My next guest has shown
off his singing voice
on both stage and screen,
he is an actor, producer, author, singer,
and the rare quintuple
threat, also a magician.
The fourth and final book
in his children's series
"The Magic Misfits" is out now.
Please welcome Neil Patrick Harris y'all.
(audience cheering)
Oh.
Oh my gosh, get in your nose.
(Kelly laughing)
- Hi Kelly.
- [Kelly] What an entrance.
- Hey, thanks.
- I gotta be honest with you,
I'm 38 years old,
and I still get a kick
out of a magnifying glass,
so (laughs) it's funny.
- Who doesn't?
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- I stopped frying bugs though
when I was much younger.
- Oh my gosh,
I used to do that with paper,
not you know, living things.
But, yeah, I would burn holes in paper.
But it's been a few years
since we've seen each other, right?
- It has been a few years.
I can't see you at all.
I see a big, giant screen
- Wow, you're missing out
- That says Kelly Clarkson.
- 'cause I look hot.
I look so good right now
you're missing this pink
- Oh my God, is there any way
- Loveliness.
- On my Zoom, Zoom land...
- You should probably figure
There you are!
it out Neil.
Yeah exactly.
- [Neil] Oh my gosh, what...
- You're welcome.
You're welcome.
- Are living in your pink greatness.
- Yes, with someone else's hair, Neil.
But it's fine.
(audience laughing)
- I almost wore that.
(Kelly laughing)
- You'd probably look better, you jerk.
So, wait, I actually just
celebrated 18 years since Idol
and it made me think of you,
because I remember you telling me,
'cause somebody was talking
about "A Moment Like This",
that people use it for weddings a lot
and I was like,
"I remember Neil telling me that..."
Was that y'all's dance?
Was that the song that you--
- That was our first dance song.
That was our song, Kelly Clarkson.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- We don't have
many people in our lives
that we talk like 13 year
old school girls about.
(laughing)
You are one of them
and that song we met
during I think Season Two
of American Idol,
when it was still this giant juggernaut
and I think that song was playing a lot
and was still connected with
and so we were falling
in love at that same time
and the lyrics to that song
always kinda stayed with us
and we always said, if
we ever got married,
that would be a great first dance song.
Especially with two guys,
- What honestly, every...
Some people wait a lifetime
for a moment like this,
some people stuck forever
for that one special kiss.
It was so perfect,
then our parents were there
and we got to dance with them.
- Oh my God I love your smile,
you're like reliving it.
- And it was to go voice.
(Kelly laughing)
- But anyway, I also know
you're really into Halloween.
I am as well, and it's coming up,
so are you guys trick
or treating this year?
Like, we don't really
know what protocol is,
I think I'm gonna throw
a dance party in my house
with my kids and me.
- Yeah, I'm not sure either,
I love Halloween, like I love Christmas.
Maybe more so in certain ways,
'cause I don't have to
buy a bunch of gifts,
but maybe less so in certain ways
'cause I don't get a bunch of
gifts, although candy counts.
So I don't know, we
usually do a family picture
and we may still figure that out,
although our resources
are limited staying here.
We're not in the city, we
normally live in New York City
and we have a little farmhouse
that we just finished and we moved into.
So we're here, which
is a bit more suburban,
a bit more normal, which is great.
At the same time, I'm not sure.
I think because of the situation
we'll probably encourage everyone
like our kids and us to
go trick and treating
if we can wearing masks,
like finding a costume
that was mask specific.
And then hope that
there's protocols in place
so that we can still social distance.
I love the quintessential walking
down the sidewalk seeing the house,
should we go into this house
and walking up and knocking on the door
and waiting for someone to open the door.
So I hope that some of that kinda happen.
It's not just buckets of candy,
like thrown on the streets,
and you just have
to fend for yourselves.
(laughing)
- Thrown at you.
- But yeah, well make a (mumbles)
- [Kelly] But wait, you'll
do a card though, right?
You said the photo, but don't
y'all do a card every year?
- We sort of released a picture
like a instagramy picture
of us in some sort of fun costume.
So we did it really when
the kids were much younger
and then we just keep doing it every year.
It's fun for me to do a little
Photoshop here and there
and that was, yeah, the
Haunted Mansion at Disney.
How can you not do that one here?
So we have an idea,
but it's not gonna be quite as outlandish.
I don't think as in years past,
but I do like to keep the
spirit of Halloween alive
anyway I'm able.
- Oh, I think it's so fun.
I'm like not even about a
party unless it has a theme.
So obviously, I love Halloween.
This is such a great book.
So this is the final book in
your children's series, right?
- I was asked to write a
middle grade fiction book
and I said I do it if I
could write four of them
and I wanted to write about magic,
and I wanted to write about kids
'cause I have two of them,
and I love the father
And so I wanted to write something
that had to do with real magic
'cause I love magic, cards
and coins and an illusion
not Potter magic and wands and
wizards and things like that.
And so that's what I did.
And each book Chronicle
is one of these four kids
that lives in a fictional
town called Mineral Wells
and each book is through the perspective
of one of those kids and so
we're at the fourth book.
It's a girl named Ridley Larsen.
She's a wheelchair bound,
awesome, amazing chick
who is all about transformation,
turning one thing into another thing.
You see the book even
looks like a playing card.
All four look like that.
So she's super amazing
dealing with her mom,
dealing with her stresses
and figuring out who the the evil guy is
in this awful magic group
called the Emerald Ring,
who's disbanded them, who's
burned the magic shop down
and this is the final story
where it all kind of comes together
and we learn all the
things we needed to know.
The book has teachers
magic tricks within it.
So if you wanna learn some magic tricks,
each book has four or five
different teacher tricks throughout.
There's codes, there's
puzzles, there's ciphers.
So I really respect readers, respect kids,
and I'm so stoked that
the books have done well
and I hope this one continues to trend.
- Yeah, no, it's obviously
done well, how innovative?
That's so cool to make them
like a part of the story,
they get to learn stuff from the book
and like kinda be part of
it, that's really cool.
- Definitely.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You like magic, right?
- I love magic and I
actually hurt like I am child
when people do magic in
front of me, it's annoying.
But you also created a
magical board game I heard,
is that real?
- That is real as well,
I love buying the games,
but I always find that
they're party games.
You know that they're--
- Do you have it there?
Can I see it?
Do you have it?
- It's like four to 12 players
and so I said why not make a
party game for just one person.
It's called Box One.
It's created just by me and
it's only for one person.
It's not something you
play with your spouse,
it's not something you play
with a group of people.
- [Kelly] Solitaire.
- If you like the codes
and the puzzles and in sort
of escape room adjacent.
- (gasps) I love escape rooms.
- I definitely suggest this for you.
I love escape rooms!
Dude, I can't get enough of them
and it's one of the things
that I am so bummed about
all this pandemic nonsense
is that you can't go to escape rooms
as much as before.
- Oh my gosh
I am obsessed with them.
- They're the best.
- It's so clever, it's
such a clever thing.
Okay, at some point
when we're allowed to
be around humans again
and they start that up
we need to do an escape room together.
- I would love to.
In the meantime, I recommend Box One
but only when you're by yourself.
- Okay, I love that.
- You can come out
and our kids, really awkward.
- "Cause I don't often have
people to play games with sometimes, so